der anfang ist gemacht in bayern und in
baden württemberg und niedersachsen und
im saarland haben gerichte die 2g regel
gekippt
schleswig holstein mit demnächst folgen
und zwar freiwillig nicht auf druck von
gerichten das heißt dort können
ungeimpfte wieder ungehindert in jedem
laden geht einkaufen wie sie wollen hat
das geschadet
keine spur also wenn man die inzidenz
werte in den vier ländern anguckt hat
sich nichts bewegt nix ist nach oben
gegangen und das ist ja auch kein wunder
ich glaube
es ist natürlich richtig und wichtig
dass der handel befreit wird aber damit
ist es nicht getan wenn also der fdp
vorsitzende christian lindner heute
vorschlägt das 2g im handel bundesweit
abgeschafft werden soll dann ist das
zwar richtig aber es springt zu kurz ich
glaube wir müssen den ungeimpften den
weg zurück ebenen in die gesellschaft
aus der sie jetzt weitgehend
ausgeschlossen sind das heißt sie müssen
auch wieder restaurants und cafés
und clubs und theater betreten können
und und und das ist ja auch nicht allzu
schwierig in wahrheit denn wir erkennen
doch heute das mit omikron dass die
geimpften so ansteckend sind wie die
ungeimpften das kann man heute einfach
so pauschal sagen die geimpften schützen
sich nur selbst gegen schwere
krankheitsverläufe aber infektiös sind
sie auch also kann man mit dem thema
ganz anders umgehen man muss damit ganz
anders umgehen und
wenn wir uns das super zu von zu
bewusstsein führen dann müssen wir doch
sagen dass die dass das pauschale
ausschließen von umgehen nicht nur
zutiefst ungerecht und unmenschlich ist
sondern auch den zweck verfehlt wenn
jetzt die berliner bürgermeister wenn
franziska giffey sagt im notfall würden
auch infizierte in krankenhäusern
eingesetzt als arbeitskräfte infizierte
und gleichzeitig werden gesunde
getestete aber nicht geimpfte
krankenpflegern und krankenpfleger
entlassen dann ist das geradezu
irrwitzig vollkommen wiedersehen ich das
heißt noch nichts anderes als dass
gesunde durch kranke ersetzt werden
sollen das ist heute der stand der
deutschen corona politik und da muss ich
sagen da müssen wir ein ende bereiten es
muss jetzt einfach
dazu übergegangen werden da kann ich nur
alle zu aufrufen auch die in der
öffentlichkeit ein wort haben
die spaltung der gesellschaft zu
überwinden
die
die verfilmung muss ich schon sagen die
verfilmung von ungeimpften
ist ein schwerer krebs schaden an der
demokratie deshalb sage ich weg mit 2g
und zwar restlos und überall und im
notfall ein wo es notwendig ist 3g das
sind die geimpften die genesenen und die
1 lasst mich noch einen jagen und
genesen und die
getesteten
gleichberechtigt ich als geimpft da sage
freiheit für die ungeimpften frei für
die jungen thorsten mann und wie nehmen
sie das wahr wie mit ungeimpften
umgegangen sind sie sind arzt in leipzig
das ist ja auch eine region wo
wahrscheinlich relativ viele ungeimpft
sind noch zumindest prozentual gesehen
in deutschland wie nehmen sie das wahr
mit
also ich kann dem ganzen erstmal nur
zustimmen dass ich sage ich das erst mal
gut dass diese irrsinnige regelung zwei
g2 g + 3g gekippt wurde mich
stimmt es eher traurig dass wir dazu
gerichte brauchen und wir eigentlich als
gesellschaft nicht mehr in der lage sind
mit vernunft ein solche themen
heranzugehen denn es ist für mich nicht
nachvollziehbar dass plötzlich ein test
den ich bei einem giften anwender zu
mehr sicherheit führt und denselben text
den ich bei den ungeimpften anwende
unsicher ist also da eine entscheidung
zu treffen wir machen zwei g2 g +
unterscheiden dass wir wissen selber
alle dass natürlich jeder der geimpft
oder gemustert ist genauso ansteckend
ist im gegenteil im moment sehe ich bei
mir in der praxis eher dass die meisten
die kommen mit positiven carola fällen
geimpft oder gemustert sind und dass
diese menschen natürlich in der breiten
masse den virus vertrag vertreiben und
andere anstecken profis sieht schreiben
schon fleißig gelben zettel das gar
nicht glauben
also ich muss vorausschicken ich bin
wirklich ich bin war noch nie ins gegen
nach dem was mir auch für uns mit wenn
man es möglich und stellt keine corona
leugnen ich war in 40 ländern der erde
und dann muss man teilweise kommt man
gar nicht rein ohne die ganzen impfungen
ich fange das ganzheitliche und zwar
wahrscheinlich etwas sagen lässt max
corinna noch nicht da war gegen grippe
geimpft geben überhaupt nichts dagegen
aber ich bin auch muss ich dazu sagen
und deswegen kann jeder bestätigen der
mich kennt eine lupenreine demokraten
das heißt ich würde mich fragen als
erstes warum verweigert leute die in
form ist hat der gründe und es hat
einfach die runde gemacht da kommen wir
dann nachher auf meinem thema das ist so
viel
opfer der impfschäden gibt es vermutlich
vermutlich verdachtsfälle auf todesfälle
im schaden und es würde zum beispiel
wenn sie einen vermummten käse haben
dann wird er sofort aus dem markt
gezogen dann wird der ganze konzern
nicht gemacht wenn sie wurden im fleisch
oder irgendwas haben sofort ein riesen
geschneidert die ganze presse und oder
wenn sie wenn nestlé baby nahrung
verteilt und sagt in 1500 sind aber
glasscherben drin ja gut aber mehr also
würden dadurch jährlich das ganze mit
glasscherben zu vergleichen denn wenn
man sich anschaut prozentual gesehen wie
viele menschen sich auf der welt haben
impfen lassen mit verschiedenen
impfstoffen muss man ja sagen dass die
vermeintlichen schäden prozentual sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr klein er richtig
aber würden sie trotzdem sie erreicht
wird schon gut gehen sondern ich gerät
von den von den leuten die vorbehalte
habe ich bin auch geimpft also aber ich
habe da nichts passiert war ich habe
mich auch sehr entfernt gehalten habe
man nicht lange schaut
die maske auf aber ich würde doch warum
der punkt ist doch wer die leute die
sich nicht impfen lassen haben große
bedenken aus verschiedenen gründen weil
es die runde gemacht hat und bisher
weder fähig noch sonst wenn du es gibt
durch und in der vieles muss man sagt ja
immer anschaut ja und man also warum ich
auch nicht eingegangen
es ist sehr oder also das hört sich
darauf eingang also jetzt muss ich per
cd m 14er ohne dass ich jetzt mal alle
einen widersprechen muss also diese
impfung ist sehr sehr sicher dass von
500 600 millionen impfungen verimpft in
allein in der eu und sie haben ja damals
in einer sendung gesagt es gebe 5000
impfschäden und dann hat sich
herausgestellt dass es da gar keinen
kausalen zusammenhang gab der
nachgewiesen wurde also ich möchte
einmal ganz kurz sagen ich halte es für
eine ethische pflicht jedes einzelnen
sich ganz deutlich damit
auseinanderzusetzen ob man sich nicht
impfen lassen kann um hier gemeinsam
auch als gesellschaft voranzukommen und
ich persönlich kann nur jedem dazu
auffordern gerade die ungeimpften sich
impfen zu lassen gerade dient jedoch
keine erstimpfung hatten ich möchte dazu
auffordern sich bitte impfen zu lassen
weil ich bin der festen überzeugung dass
wir als gesellschaft also vorankommen so
aber moment aber ich wollte ganz wichtig
weil ich eben typisch ist ich will dass
der gig mit ich will ja ganz normal zu
zu ihrer eigenen team gekommen weil sie
haben also zwei gegen
dabei bleiben möchte gerne wissen welche
möchte ganz konkret wissen von wir alle
zusammen und ethik und lasst euch doch
impfen und warum wo ist die gefahr dass
umgehend das ist doch hirnrissig wenn
der genau wenn der geliebte genauso
ansteckendes war wo liegt sie gefahren
wenn einer geht um geimpft und
getestetes könnte man kann mit irgend
jemandem erklären da haben wir uns dann
verschiedene begründungen gewöhnt die
letzte die wir gehört haben und die
jetzt gängig ist lautet man wird zwar
durch impfen nicht nicht steril und man
steckt andere durchaus weiter an aber
bei einem selbst ist halt der
krankheitsverlauf womöglich ja weniger
stressig wenn man glück hat muss aber
das ist jetzt keines so wild
durcheinander übrigens um das wir kommen
ja noch mal drauf bei seiner these es
ist halt auch so wenn die
gesundheitsbehörden in diesem fall das
rk ii robert koch institut eine
vernünftige arbeit machen würden die ich
nicht erkennen kann jetzt werden ja auch
daten geschätzt weil sie gar nicht mehr
nachkommen infizierte und so weiter dann
hätten die natürlich auch mal eine
statistik eröffnet über impfschäden und
dann wäre das dann wäre das transparent
und man wüsste wie viel sind immerhin
gemeldet worden und man könnte einer
einer solchen verdacht entgegentreten
kann man gar nicht gibt es gesicherte
zahlen über impfschäden die gibt's ja
gar dass ich oder sich eine spannende
das ist schon eine spannende these also
die frage dass sozusagen das datenchaos
des zahlen chaos auch dazu führt dass
menschen verunsichert werden weil
dadurch dass es eben keine wirklichen
daten gibt
dazu führt dass möglicherweise telegramm
und überall irgendwelche gerüchte
verbreitet also über vermeintliche
impfschäden ja ich glaube dass das ein
sehr für uns jetzt in der runde an
diesem punkt einigen können dass es
leider zu viel fett news gibt und so
viele unwahrheiten in umlauf gebracht
werden und deshalb finde ich es ganz
wichtig dass wir ganz klar daten
transparent machen und mit daten
transparenz nach außen gehen und ich
finde gerade wenn man nach den ein paar
guckt wo beispielsweise gerade viele
öffnungs schritte getätigt werden was
ich sehr gut finde da wird das ja ganz
konkret auch basierend auf daten gemacht
die vorliegenden echtzeit das ist in
deutschland leider oft nicht der fall
dass es wirklich ein großes problem da
ich glaube das ist ein punkt auf den
können wir uns einigen bei einem anderen
habe ich eine anleitung das wundert mich
hier probleme
haben werden die daten das ist ja das
große problem vom robert-koch-institut
kriegen wir jeden tag tolle statistiken
präsentiert aber ich frage mich ich als
arzt als hausarzt wo kommen diese zahlen
her also ich teste meine patienten dies
der test geht an ein labor da ist keine
verknüpfung dazu ist das jetzt ein
geimpft oder ungeimpfter die patienten
werden nicht vom gesundheitsamt gefragt
und trotzdem erscheint plötzlich daten
beim robert-koch-institut wir sagen
prozent sind geimpft und so und so viel
sinn umgehen haben sie denn man fragt ja
sag ich gefragt aber keine antwort
gekriegt das ist ein problem von
menschen die ganz normale bürger sind
die kriegen keine andere sie sind ja hat
das heißt ja sie in ihrer praxis wenn
jemand zu ihnen kommt und sich jetzt
impfen lassen will ist das möglich bei
ihnen gegen tetanus diphtherie polio
managers jederzeit alles ich eben für
keine
menschen mehr gegen kongo haben ist das
so und ist auch im schäden bei den
anderen impfung richtig dazugehört immer
eine entsprechende aufklärung und das
ist also auch ein problem warum es
vorbehalte gegen diese impfung gibt
warum ist das so weil ich ich habe eine
zeitlang geimpft und es kam dann immer
mehr patienten zu mir die ich dann im
gespräch gefragt sie wollen sich heute
gegen korona impfung und dann kannst du
dir einfach denn ich will nicht ich muss
mein arbeitgeber und meine familie und
sowas eigentlich will ich mich nicht
impfen und da muss ich sagen das
widerspricht jeglicher ärztlicher ethik
wir können nicht gegen den willen des
patienten eine impfung eine blutentnahme
eine operation ein medikament geben das
ist konsens da gibt's den nürnberger
kodex wo das ganz klar drin steht auch
in buddy die die patienten kamen wir
freiwillig zu ihnen haben dann aber von
dem druck berichtet offenbar genau
geplant das bedeutet jetzt ja nicht dass
sie gegen den willen der patienten etwas
in den rahmen ram doch ich muss
entscheidend ist dass ein freier wille
des patienten oder ist er unter druck
entstanden steht auch so drinnen im
nürnberger kodex können sie gerne
nachlesen und das machen wir uns immer
klar auch bei der aufklärung wie weit
versteht der patient eigentlich was ich
gerade mit dem patienten spreche ich
kann im mediziner latein das erzählen
und er legt das alles ab sie bekommen
auch sachspenden sie sagen sie wollen
wir empfehlen also ich will jetzt weil
ich warte schon so lange drauf das ist
richtig bitter ist richtig dass ich
irgendwie trotzdem nicht weil ich habe
oder wir haben in leipzig genug andere
möglichkeiten und ich kann die patienten
dort auch hin verweisen für mich ist
wichtig diese freiwilligkeit in der
impfung aber wenn jemand freiwillig
kommt dann ein hallo zum nein das sage
ich trotzdem noch auf einen dreier
freuen weil ja das mag sein dass er
freiwillig bei mir ist weil ich das aber
nicht mehr vor bewerten kann inwieweit
sich diese freiwilligkeit ein ausdruck
ist oder ob es doch druck gibt so denn
viele kommen wirklich und wir spüren
alle den druck den der bevölkerung geht
wir haben mit 2g 3g angefangen also wie
freiwillig sind wir denn eigentlich noch
in unseren händen zu anderen impfungen
wie weit sind wir denn in unseren
entscheidungen
ob ich kann da ich drauf bleiben aber
bei unserer armen habe ich nicht sagen
aber